>> Sean: NOW A OUR FRIEND
STEPHEN A. SMITH HAS A NEW BOOK
CALLED "STRAIGHT SHOOTER."
INSPIRING MEMOIR RISE TO FAME,
SUCCESS IN SPORTS MEDIA AND
OVERCAME A LEARNING DISABILITY
AND VERY ROUGH CHILDHOOD.
THERE IS A PREMIER LIVE SIGNING
AFTER THE SHOW.
I'LL BE MODERATING AND INTERVIEW
ING STEPHEN.
STEPHENASMITHBOOK.COM.
IT IS FIVE MINUTES AFTER THE
SHOW EASTERN.
MEMOIR OF SECOND CHANCES AND
FIRST TAKES.
THIS IS WHEN YOU ARE ON MY RADIO
SHOW AN HOUR.
HARD HOUR.
WE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS A LONG
TIME.
WE NEVER GOT THIS DEEP.
THIS IS TRIUMPH TO TRAGEDY BOOK.
I HAD NO IDEA ABOUT THE PAIN YOU
WENT THROUGH AS A CHILD.
LEFT BACK IN THE THIRD GRADE,
HAD TO GO TO SUMMER SCHOOL.
HAD TO REDO FOURTH GRADE.
OVERHEARD CONVERSATION, DAD WAS
NOT A PARTICULARLY GOOD MAN IN A
LOT OF WAYS.
LET YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF, YOU
HEAR YOUR FATHER DESCRIBE YOU AS
BEING STUPID.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW PAINFUL THAT
WAS.
TALK ABOUT IT.
>> HE DEFINITELY SAID IT.
HE SAID THE BOY AIN'T SMART.
HE ISN'T GOING TO DO ANYTHING
WITH HIS LIFE.
GET OVER IT.
I HEARD HIM SAY IT.
AS PAINFUL AS IT WAS TO HEAR
THAT, COMBINE WITH THE LAUGHTER
FROM THE KIDS ON THE BLOCK
MINUTES EARLIER, IT WAS
INCREDIBLE SOURCE OF MOTIVATION.
KNOWING MY FATHER FELT THAT WAY
ABOUT ABOUT ME AND LITTLE FAITH,
THAT WAS A START OF LEVEL OF
DETERMINATION I HAVE NEVER LET
GO OF IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
A LOT OF TIMES AS AYATOLLAH
KHAMANEI -- ADULTS, HOW
LINGERING IT CAN BE.
SOMETIMES IT CAN MOTIVATE YOU TO
EXCEED EXPECTATIONS, MAKE LIARS
OUT OF DOUBTERS AND AXEL TO
HEIGHTS UNKNOWN, UNSEEN AND
UNIMAGINED.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT I BELIEVE I
DID.
>> Sean: TALK ABOUT INCREDIBLE
MOTHER AND SISTERS IN THIS BOOK.
THEY DIDN'T CALL IT AT THE TIME
IT WAS, YOU HAD DYSLEXIA.
THEY DISCOVERED AND TAUGHT YOU
HOW TO READ.
YOU TELL THE STORY ABOUT ONE
TEACHER THAT BRINGS YOUR MOM IN
AND SAYS:  I HATE TO TELL YOU
THIS, YOUR SON IS REALLY, REALLY
SMART.
NOT ONLY REALLY SMART, IF HE IS
NOT INTERESTED HE IS NOT GOING
TO PAY ATTENTION.
FIND THE THING HE IS MOST
INTERESTED IN AND GOING TO BE A
STAR.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED?
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: I HATE TO ADMIT IT
PUBLICALLY, A STAR.
>> [LAUGHTER] I AM THANKFUL HE
SAID THAT TO MY MOTHER AND ME.
DEFINITELY ELEVATED MY
CONFIDENCE TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
MADE ME THAT MUCH MORE FOCUSSED
AND HELPED ME TO FIND MY PASSION
WHICH WAS SPORTS.
ONCE I READ AND WATCHED SPORTS
IT BUILT MY CONFIDENCE.
READING NEWS, POLITICS, CURRENT
EVENTS A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
I WOULD NEVER BELIEVE.
SUDDENLY COMPREHENSION.
>> Sean: YOU SENT ME TEXTS
TELLING ME HOW LONG I AM?
>> THIS IS FOUR, FIVE DAYS A
WEEK YOU ARE WRONG.
NOWHERE IN THE BALLPARK.
YOU NEED HELP.
THAT IS WHAT I AM HERE FOR.
>> Sean: I WANT TO REMIND OUR
AUDIENCE, THIS BOOK IS
PHENOMENAL.
TRAGEDY TO TRIUMPH "STRAIGHT
SHOOTER."
HEAD T